thank you
hey so I'm Julie Lavoie and I'm gonna
talk about I say what's munching using
machine learning to extract the
publication dates of news articles can
you hear me okay
no is that better okay cool
I would just like to start by saying a
pro tip which is don't go get something
to eat 40 minutes before your talk in a
city that you don't know and get lost
which is what happened to me so I'm glad
I'm here on time um okay so I'm gonna
start and so I'd like to thank sawhorse
media who are clients of mine for
letting me speak about work that I did
for them I'm not used to having a mic
like this so if I wander too far away
and you can't hear me please just let me
know so let's say you want to get the
date of one page that's pretty
straightforward right you just use
scraping um you can use um scrape B or
beautiful super L XML or whatever your
tool is of choice you can kind of look
at the Dom and extract the date from
there that's pretty straightforward
and since sites use templates if you can
extract one page from a site you can
typically extract them all let's say if
we add a second site to this that's also
fairly straightforward the first site
was New York Times
this is Gizmodo you just add like a
another case right if it's New York
Times do this if it's Gizmodo do that
I'm using the same technique and you're
golden however what if we want to
extract the date of any page that's kind
of a lot harder so you can kind of keep
on going with the same sort of method by
for 10-15 sites but what if we have
10,000 sites are we going to write a
program that has 10,000 cases that's
kind of ridiculous right well what do we
do now well we could get people to do it
so we could use something like
Mechanical Turk which has an API you can
send TAS to real humans it costs about a
cent per page obvious things it's kind
of cool because it's like programming
people um it's a little bit kind of
vertiginous to me that essentially human
cognition has kind of become just one
tiny part of a greater computation not
even a really particularly well valued
part one zen per page of a greater
computation that's mostly done by
machines right the problem is well this
isn't that scalable so in our case we
process about a million pages per week
so that would be ten grand per week you
know that kind of adds up and you can
kind of guess at 1 cent per page
well the quality's
always there some foreshadowing is we're
gonna need this anyways okay so well we
could get a programmer to do it so we
could look at the data you see a pattern
you write some kind of like program
algorithm that uses heuristics so you
could do something like let's say if
you've seen the text it says publish
blah blah takes the date from there if
you don't see that look for a div that
says a publication date or pub date or
something like that has a class like
that and then take it there and if not
do something else
solutions like this can be really good
first approximation however the problem
is sometimes the pattern can be a bit
more complex than a human being can
understand the foreshadowing is what
we're gonna need this as part of our
overall solution anyways or we could get
out the big guns we could get machine
learning to do it machine learning is
cool because it can essentially quote
unquote see a pattern that's more
complex than humans can see machine
learning is also interesting because it
includes both previous solutions so
we're gonna do supervised learning which
essentially means we're showing a bunch
of examples where we know the answer
ahead of time to the model and asking it
to sort of extra asking it to
extrapolate what to do when we don't
know the answer ahead of time to kind of
see a pattern that we can use later on
so we're gonna need humans to get
examples of pages and dates to train the
model right so we're not really going to
escape data entry and we're gonna need
heuristics to kind of figure out the
features to tell the model to pay
attention to as well so we're not gonna
escape that part of it either
however machine learning so giant pain
in that it's an enormous amount of work
and we should only really use it if the
volume of our data or the problem
complexity is too much for previous
solutions so I had a friend who wanted
to parse dates she I was telling her
about what I was working on she was
thinking of her an intern to do it and
she said oh maybe I'll just use machine
learning instead and so I asked her well
how much data do you have and she's like
I have two thousand results and I said
do you have two thousand today and 2,000
tomorrow or just like flat-out two
thousands like just two thousand and I'm
like just do it by hand like even faster
than training an intern you're gonna get
an intern you're gonna give them
directions it'll get them wrong um you
know they won't show up on time you'll
have to run after them you'll have to
clean the data Excel make typos just
literally do it by hand or seam problem
with mechanical
so you kind of have to use what's
appropriate for the amount of data and
the complexity the problem anyhow great
so okay so to bring it back to machine
learning well where to start I like to I
really like this type of problem because
it you have to kind of start by thinking
how do I as a human think of this
problem right so how do we recognize the
publication date so if we look at this
page how do we know right
so I guess a bunch of things that we
think about is well it's probably close
to the title it's probably close to the
author how do we know something's the
title while it's usually like a bunch of
really big text at the top of the page
right like close to the main body the
author that's a bit more thorny it looks
like a human name which is a lot harder
problem you know The Hobbit page it
looks like a date has numbers in it
there's month month words these are the
week words it's typically not in the
footer it's typically not in the
comments or here you have like top
stories well we know it's probably not
there because there's a bunch of smaller
things and they're all grouped together
and like they seem less significant so
we have essentially three different
kinds of cues that we can drawn to kind
of figure this out so you have language
cues like it says updated you have
rendering presentation cues so the kinds
of things they would teach to someone in
graphic design school so it's near the
top close to the title close to the
author where it's positioned how big is
it that kind of thing and finally we
have markup cues so things that are
typically not meant to be read by a
human unless you're like a web developer
so things it's Anna did that has a class
of publication date it's in a time tag
but even though normally a human is not
going to see these things reading a page
we can still use this right so these
cues are so strong that even in a
language that we don't necessarily
understand this is from a Japanese
publication online um we can often
actually kind of muddle through and
figure out what's the publication aid of
course if you read Japanese or you read
Chinese characters and maybe this is
look a bit more obvious to you than the
rest of us but let's let's pretend none
of us know and and take a wild guess
rate you can kind of see at the top you
know if you read one website that's
probably the menu to the side is
probably related stories on the big you
know the there's a picture and then
there's a main body of the attacks
like the Prime Minister Japan and you
can kind of see there's a social sharing
bar even though like the the names are
Japanese you can see Twitter Facebook
all that stuff and on top you can see
that's probably the title and under that
you see it's like 2016 and then some
stuff and some more numbers and let's
take a wall guess that's probably when
this article is published right at least
if I was betting my own money this is
what I would say let's make it even
harder so here's a page from a tiny
newspaper um and it's the same thing how
do we figure out what's the publication
date of this article I don't even really
know what this article is about like I
was looking at what like what is this
picture even but you can kind of see
like there's an advertisement there's a
video something there's the title and
tie is even harder because it actually
uses the Buddhist year so it's not 2016
in Thailand it's like 2500 something and
so we can also guess however because we
see the time we see 0 9 22 and then 25
9:25 59 I'm gonna guess that's the
Buddhist year and that's probably the
publication date for this publication so
there's a lot we can draw and even if
like the language and the characters
that we might not even know what's going
on so okay so now we've kind of thought
a little bit about the problem in
general terms let's bring it back to
machine learning the hardest part for me
what I found on of machine learning is
kind of setting up the problem in a way
the machine learning can answer it's
sort of like they say about jokes right
it's okay you set them up and I knock
them down it's like you have to set up a
problem in a way that machine learning
can answer so this was actually the
first machine like I had been a web
developer for several years and work on
data projects but this was the first
project who I really started to use
machine learning in production and I was
very much Hulk by the CTO I was working
with at the time and we're kind of like
discussing how are we gonna approach
this found this research paper online
and that's what I ended up implementing
so if you're interested in this topic in
more depth like there's a lot more
information in this paper so there's
basically if you've done machine
learning at all this will be very
familiar to you there's two phases
there's like training the model and then
using a model in production and I'm
gonna talk about it's kind of hard to
kind of give an overview of the stop so
I'm gonna briefly go into and I'm going
over all of them
tell us so if these maxi slides don't
make how much science don't worry like
it's gonna become more clear so in
training this is how we break down the
problem so we get some data the data
looks like a bunch of HTML pages and the
publication date that we know like we
get a human to say this is when this was
published and we just get a big list of
that stuff for each of these pages we're
going to split it into chunks a chunk is
essentially a Dom element that contains
something that's a date that could be
the publication date or could just be
some random crap from the comments we
don't know yet and then for each of
these Dom elements we're going to do
feature selection for and it calculates
features on each of these chunks and
then we're gonna use this and we're phim
this into the model to Train it in
production there's a few more extra
stops so we go through all this now we
don't have a bunch of pages we just have
one page we want to know the publication
date we do the first few things the same
we take that page put into chunks
calculate futures on the chunks and then
pass this feature vector to the train
classifier I get a label the label is
going to be is this the publication date
or is this not and then we have a few
more steps so let's say for a page you
get three chunks you pass them to the
classifier the classifier size two of
these have the publication date how do
we decide right which one is actually
the real date so how do we just have a
you ate that that's one step then as you
recall the chunk is like a bunch of
Markov maybe some tax and a date
I'll show examples it'll be a bit more
clear on so you got an extract the date
from the string for not thing and then
fine-tuning of the whole solution so
step one okay so let's like go through
these in more detail which will make
more sense you got to start by getting
data it's pretty hard to end up with a
good solution at the end if you start of
crop data I've always really loved this
quote by Charles Babbage one of the
fathers of computer science which kind
of shows that getting good data has been
a problem for a long time so people are
asking him if you put in wrong data into
the machine can you get the right answer
and he's like the I guess the 1864
equivalent of like WTO if he's like I'm
not able rightly to apprehend the kind
of confusion of ideas that could provoke
such a question so even back then it was
very important to get good data and
Charles Babbage knew this so let's start
dito for this project look like would be
sweet like a massive CSV with URLs and
got some people our node asked to look
at the page and enter the date in the
CSV
it looked exactly like this it's a URL
that's a publication date look at it
right the publication name that's it I
downloaded all the pages to use this
training data one thing I found is
people are often wrong and so what I did
is I got three people to fill in the
same CSV and I only take the result if
all of them agree that eliminated a lot
of error so this being my first machine
learning project I became quickly
acquainted with the fact that sorry we
focused on English and all but I can
answer more questions at the end too but
that that's a very good question we
focused on English but yeah let's talk
about about that a bit more at the end
um so I quickly became very quaint
edoardo get a whole bunch of data it's
just like a ginormous pain and that and
here are examples of problems that I
discovered so for example someone would
enter the correct publication date and
did I say SV and then like a week later
when I'm like downloading this stuff in
parsing it the web page is gone 404 one
problem that I was actually really hard
to figure out was some articles have
publication dates when you view them in
the browser so when someone is doing the
data entry but when I go and download it
or through cross I don't get any data
because the site uses react or another
JavaScript framework we have to render
the page the access to the data so you
just get like an empty page or just like
a bunch of JavaScript with no content
inside and that was really hard to
figure out like why it wasn't working
I'm just general like CSV and utf-8 or
her utf-8 is lower the bane of my
existence
and just like data entry problems so I
would tell people if the page is 404
enter like n slash aid I decided that
was the thing nice I'd just drop that
result and of course people enter na
underscore na like they just like how
many ways can you literally not enter
the thing that I told you to enter it's
just crazy of course then I can say fine
I'll just look for all the missing a
have to go and look for all those stupid
misspellings I self
through the whole thing it's just like
like I don't know I started feeling like
when you're like a kindergarten teacher
and you're trying to tell people like
color inside the line in their coloring
like what is even going on and just flat
out so people enter incorrect results
just because they make a mistake
obviously and sometimes they just don't
even care and um okay so let's assume
now all our data is great in some
magical world so now we want to split it
into chunks so chunk being a Dom element
that contains a date so here's hopefully
to help you visualize it a little bit
your examples of chunks so it's like so
markup a date maybe some tax sometimes
there's no tax sometimes it's like a
meta tags and stuff like that but here
are examples and so this is fairly easy
for dates because dates have a limited
number of formats that they really come
in on I've used the same approach for
extracting authors and that's much more
difficult because there's no regular
expression for what's a human name
that's a much harder problem so I used a
combination of regular expressions and
I'll XML basically what I did is I took
the HTML page I slurped it into a big
like Alex ml tree and I just literally
just iterate over every single thing in
the tree and say does this look like a
date yes I take it does this look like a
date nope just like ignore and move on
um we need the chunk not just the date
for the reasons kind of always talking
about before that there's a lot of
information in the markup that is like
useful for us so that's why we don't
just take the date we take like the
actual markup that includes the water so
feature selection is the next step um
this is actually why sometimes it's a
good idea for this type of problem to
not just jump straight into machine
learning but maybe to build a heuristic
solution and I have read stories from a
lot of startups were like that's often
how they start with they're kind of like
data science type products and one good
reason is because a lot of features can
come from the ideas that you came up
with using heuristics in the beginning
mike is obviously I was very much helped
by the fact that this paper just like
listed all the features that they used
and that's what I implemented most of
them and I added a few kind of I thought
of myself so examples of features were
stuff like containing the word posted
modified publish Isaak
gasps that correlates fairly highly with
having the publication date um stuff
like the Hatter level like is it an h1
and h2 and h3 tag um is it laying is it
bold or not stuff like the pixel
distance from the top of the page the
pixel distance from the title like those
are examples of features
yeah I'm take literally everything that
looks like a date and I'm gonna do this
election of what is the publication date
like afterwards so at that stage I could
have the same date like a few times and
I have more than one date at that point
I'm just literally like these are
candidates that could be the publication
date and I'm gonna do features election
and machine learning on like all of
these things and eliminate a bunch of
them that's it I'm just like taking this
I'm taking the date I sorry I'm taking
these chunks this is the input into you
and I'm calculating features on them and
then this is the input into you the
classifier obviously I'm also taking the
label in the sense of this is data that
I know ahead of time like this how this
does have the publication date or not
sorry no no okay
so future selection so at this point so
now I've I have these like basically
where am i sorry I just got a bit lost
so now I have like essentially these
feature vectors of like all this
information I've calculated on these
chunks and now I'm going to train the
model um this is kind of phrased in
terms of a classification problem at the
chunk level at the level of this Dom
element essentially labeled this does
this there's two labels does this
contain the publication date or not so
like yes or no essentially I used an L
TK and naivebayes you could use
scikit-learn whatever your favorite like
Python machine learning library is I'm
sure there's a lot of people in this
room that can tell me way better stuff I
could have used um I basically picked
this frankly because it was the easiest
one to understand um I literally what I
did is I read the an LT cage tutorial
and to me it was understandable and then
I looked at the scikit-learn tutorial
and I'm like I have no idea what's even
going on here so I was like all right an
ulti cait is so this is how I felt doing
this tutorial um I don't know if you
found the same thing but for me whenever
I've tried to learn a new technological
thing like at some longtime ago I
decided was going to learn
you do this little like let's make a
blog tutorial you look wow I can I can
do rails and I'm so smart now and then
it was the same thing with me she's like
oh I can machine learning all the things
and this is so great and I felt really
awesome and then this is like any real
production problem once you're done the
tutorial
this problem is totally like this like I
loved it and I found it really
interesting to work on but there's
definitely just a lot of meaty gritty
that was hard to figure out um and this
is like a super cheesy graphic but I
just want to choose it so now the model
is trained and we can use in production
so there's a few more steps with respect
to now using in production so kind of to
answer that I'll probably this answers
your question little bit in the back um
let's say for a given page right you
split it into chunks you calculate the
future as you pass it to the classifier
in the classifier size like let's say
there's three chunks and two of them
come out as this has the publication
date um how do we decide which one to
take because this is actually a much
easier problem for the question of dates
because an article is typically he only
has one publication date if you're
trying to get things like the author it
happens all the time the articles have
multiple authors so it's not just like
there can be only one and you pick one
it's like you have to figure out with
like which one there could be multiple
and so this is a much simpler problem
than finding author so I essentially
really just tried a whole bunch of stuff
and then tested it to see which one had
like core like had the best accuracy I
tried basically picking the first chunk
that got labeled is true like as having
a publication date I picked I tried
picking last one I tried picking the one
that hath like occurred the most often
in the page like I counted how many
times it is a curve versus the other
candidates
I tried picking the one that occurs the
most often in the list of true chunks
like you got a whole bunch of chunks
that were labeled as a public media it
turns out what worked out the best is
literally just picking the first one
just because my best guess is it just
correlates with being at the top of the
page which is usually where the
publication date is so that just kind of
worked out that's the best thing and
then as you recall the chunk is like a
bunch of markup the date some text we
want to ditch now we want to now that we
don't need the markup in the text
anymore I want to get rid of it and just
return their date right so we just use a
regex to kind of extract
out of the chunk and then fine-tuning so
this is like a bunch of prefilled
training post filtering and just
flat-out hacks I did
so pre-filtering at the stage where
you're turning things into Alex ml tree
I just flat-out just ditch anything that
lead that just never really has the
publication date so anything that looks
like a comment anything in the footer
anything that's like related stories top
stories popular stories I'm like okay
get rid of it all get rid of images on
videos in JavaScript so JavaScript has a
lot of false positives because if you
have a link to the the library hosted
somewhere else it often has a date in
the URL and that was like a ton of false
positives from there also because that's
typically at the top of the page in the
head and the header so I just like get
rid of that as well um for post
filtering I removed just results they're
obviously wrong so basically dates are
in the future pretty obviously that
can't be the date and then I also remove
dates are in the past but there was
actually kind of a gotcha with this
where I said okay if something is before
let's say 1980 or close to the
beginnings of the web I can't really be
the day or something on a website so I'm
I'll just let me need that however there
are sites like the New York Times where
they've started to put historical
articles online so you do have legit
articles where they digitized it but it
was published in like 1863 and it's like
on the New York Times website so now you
can't eliminate that like you have to
actually leave those in so now what I do
is I reject things before the 1500s
thinking I'm safe but preparing this
talk it occurred to me I should really
if I wanted to be like super hardcore
go to like the date of the printing
press when it was invented and just like
make that my cutoff point so there's
like no eras and the last thing was
basically just flat-out a hack but and I
this I only thought about at the I'm
like after iterating over this several
times and like looking what kind of
errors came out on and this was like I'm
super proud of this hack and this was
literally like a 10% increase in
accuracy just from this which is if
there's a date in the URL which happens
a lot for sites that use like a CMS so
here's an example which is was this is
cool it was like some sort of thing
about having metal a natural language
proof this thing that I was reading and
I can guarantee you that it was probably
published on April 20th 2016 so if you
see a date in the URL for an article
literally ignore everything I just said
and just take it out of the URL and that
is almost always the publication date
the only time this is wrong is if like
let's say it's published on April 20th
and then they make a modification the
next day the public the CMS x8 so the
URL stays fixed but the actual
publication they will be like April 21st
that's the only time see aberrant so
like that was like a massive thing to
discover that I didn't think about
before I started results so this program
is essentially has 88% precision on
article sampled from 550,000
publications which is how many
publications we parse in production the
paper itself had around 96 percent
precision I kind of like very loosely
average it because they measured it over
like different research datasets I
didn't use their data set because I I
wasn't trying to match their result for
the sake of research I was just trying
to parse the stuff that I had to parse
but I just kind of used the result of
the paper as a kind of upper bound and
when I can hope to achieve um there are
several reasons I can think of why these
results might be different the first one
would be I think I'm pretty smart
hopefully that's true but I'm not five
people with a PhD in machine learning so
that was probably responsible for that
small difference or that difference um
the other one is that I use a fairly
naive algorithm and they use like
something more complicated right now you
can look it up in the paper or I can
look up later if you care and as well
there's a few features that they
implemented that I had to leave out um
for reasons I'll talk about right now
I'm just gonna get some water
so I also came across things that
basically highlighted sort of the
difference between doing something in
production and doing something for
research purposes the major one was that
features that had to do with the
headless browsers so stuff like
calculating the pixel distance between
the title
and the publication date are the
publication in the author for us ended
up being too slow to do in production
basically we parse about 300,000 pages
per day versus like for research purpose
you just lose a bit chugging along in
the lab until it's done and you have
your result so we ended up leaving those
out and you can kind of guess that how
close it is to the title probably
correlates very strongly so that that's
probably part of the difference in
accuracy as well one difference for us
was that for us it's much worse to
return the wrong answer than to return
no answer so in the post filtering I
kind of like skewed it in favor of like
if I don't feel completely sure just
like reject this whole thing I'll take
like just [ __ ] nothing versus take the
chance on writing something wrong versus
research I think you would just care
about like the kind of true results you
can compare how well you're doing so
that was like two major differences and
so if I wanted to finish I guess with
lessons learned so when I started on
this project I was only one in my
organization I was working with data I
had a really smart CTO to kind of bounce
ideas off of but I also you know he I
didn't have experience with machine
learning and neither did he and I just
had a lot of problems that my web
development friends just didn't have so
I had like knowing to really talk to you
about my problems which is always kind
of a sad position in life and so I
watched a lot of PI data talks to try to
understand best practices and how did
people organize their code and kind of
what do they do so I wanted to list them
here as well so one thing I found super
useful that I learned from doing this
project was that it's really useful
before you go and collect a whole ton of
data to kind of go through the whole
process and set up like a data pipeline
with some tiny set of data so like say
for this problem to basically take 20 or
elles like do the data entry by hand
just myself and Lily set up the entire
data pipeline you know write one like
super copy feature and train the
classifier obviously with the resultant
won't be significant and just make sure
look at every step everything is in the
format that I need it to be before you
go and just collect tons of data that
turns out to be wrong that's actually a
problem that happened with this where I
had to like do tons of data
transformation because I gave I I didn't
really know it's only partway through
that I really realized how I really need
versus knowing from the beginning so now
what I do is I just kind of do that a
tiny data pipeline at the beginning and
not really helps me a lot
um with respect to collecting data in a
spreadsheet if I were you have to do
this if you have a like a CSV I found it
like I used to give people directions
and literally everyone just call my
directions wrong like all the time and
it also just makes you sound like super
picky but it is picky right so now what
I do is I just give example so if I'm
giving people like a huge CSV to fill
out I'll just fill out the first like
ten examples and just like fill it out
exactly you know if the pages 404 do
this if you know the date should be in
exactly this format like just literally
give people like how they can't get it
wrong um if it's if you're getting
people to collect the data online often
it's people were English and honestly
their first language
so I found that the clearer your
instructions the better like don't use
slang don't use idioms don't like kind
of ask them to kind of understand things
from contacts like just be very precise
and like clear um and another thing that
was like very very helpful that also I
didn't do for this project and I learned
to do it it is basically write tools to
kind of debug your data pipeline at each
stage um if this is something that you
know about for me like this is kind of
how I forget about myself
if there's some framework or tools to do
this like better I would love if someone
if you know about this like come and
talk to me about it cuz I'm very
interested in learning about this more
um but for example the problem with
finding like pages that have no data
because of react doc took a long time to
figure out because it's like you're
parsing something you get to answer it
well where is it going wrong it's
actually going wrong Lu the page has no
data there's nothing wrong with like how
I'm picking out chunks there's nothing
wrong with the classifier there's
nothing wrong and yeah I thought there's
literally no data to parse that's where
it's wrong but it takes a long time to
figure that out if you don't have an
easy way to like inspect the data to see
where where is this kind of like going
wrong so now what I do is I just
literally at every stage I just hit
right tools sort of like I'd write unit
tests for the features to make sure the
features get calculated correctly now I
would write like kind of data inspection
tools to like a look at the data each
step of the pipeline and so I guess to
finish on this was I guess the biggest
thing to learn and was it I guess
my thinking on working with machine
learning versus more sort of traditional
algorithms someone wrote this on Twitter
the and it was one of those things that
sounded quite right until it kind of
sunk in over time and I started thinking
is actually quite deep which is that
machine learning is about thinking
statistically versus algorithmically and
so let's say for this problem if you
have a hundred pages 99 of them will
have the data at the top and one of them
will have a Z at the bottom for some
inexplicable reason um if you write
something that's correct for those 99
pages most likely it's going to get that
last page wrong but of course that's
much better than getting one correct a
99 wrong which is which I make if I make
the opposite assumption like the dates
are usually at the bottom and so at
least what I found is that for machine
learning it's often for problems where
there's no option to get 100 of them
right that's just not possible and so
it's kind of you're searching for what's
right most of the time versus something
that's algorithmically cracked where you
would consider that wrong answer to be a
bog versus what it is in this case which
is just kind of the cost of doing
business so thank you for listening to
my talk
thanks to these people for listening to
other versions of it and helping improve
it um and then if you want to talk to me
now versus talk to me later um I don't
really do QA but you're welcome to come
and talk to me in person with any
questions or comments or anything that
you want to talk about I'll be here and
I'll be at the conference and then if
you have data problems that you want to
talk about later um here's my contact
information I'm done thank you very much
you